this video was sponsored by the purge on
USA Network a 10-episode television
events watch the purge Tuesdays on USA
Network and stick around the end of this
video if you want to hear about how this
episode sets up for the events of the
purge election year let's roll that
intro welcome back to things you missed
if it feels like we just purged a few
episodes ago it's because we're getting
over five times the purge coverage this
year in today's video I'll be breaking
down everything you might have missed in
what is America the first episode of
this new series the first thing we see
is a shower head beginning to dispense
water this is a significant shot to open
on because one of the ideologies of the
purge is that it's a way for the upper
class to cleanse society of the poor the
homeless and the mentally ill I've
talked about the reasoning for this
before but to quickly sum it up these
are all groups that rely on government
money to fund food stamps shelters etc
so the purge is more of an excuse to
remove these groups and there are
actually many instances with these
corrupt politicians using the word
cleanse to describe the purge so who is
this group that's being cleansed in the
showers it's the robed purge cult
possibly called the OMF that we see
giving themselves up to perjures as part
of a ritual so they're cleansing
themselves for this ritual they also
show great support for the idea of the
purge since they've been brainwashed
into believing that they're not dying
but going to this place called the
invisible ever since the first purge and
this takes place about ten years after
blue flowers have been a symbol of
support for the purge the cult displays
these flowers outside of their school
the ones who are being purged have blue
robes blue towels they ride in a blue
school bus and even blue showers strobe
things I don't really know what they're
called it seems that they're allowed to
switch from yellow robes to blue when
they're old enough as mentioned by the
kids Miguel encounters when looking for
his sister and only after they've taken
this ritualistic shower to cleanse
themselves for the perjures because
after the shower they change into the
blue robes and the yellow robes can be
seen hanging on the hook in the
background in her letter to me go
penelope mentions that she'll be joining
their parents on the anniversary of
their giving and then later at the cult
training school it's revealed that their
parents lives were taken on the night of
the very first purge I'm not sure if
that's a reference to the test purge
that took place on Staten
in the movie entitled the first verge or
if they're referring to the first
nationwide purge that would have taken
place the year after that I'd like to go
back and re-watch the first purge and
see if there are any references to the
parents or anything but at the time of
making this video it's not out on
blu-ray yet but if you remember anything
or happen to watch this video later on
please do leave your findings in the
comments I also have a theory about why
these kids are willing to sacrifice
their lives the first place that Miguel
goes to try to find his sister is a
rehabilitation center we don't know
whether she's a drug addict or an
alcoholic but either one of these would
put her in a group of people that the
nffa political party is trying to
eliminate I think this freaky lady who's
the leader of the cult is an NF F a
member who's rounded up these kids or
young adults who are recovering because
they're in a state where they can be
easily manipulated
she then tricks them into believing
they're doing something good by
sacrificing themselves to the purge
another piece of evidence to support
that theory is that in this iteration of
the purge we learn the answer to a long
pondered fan question what happens to
hospitals during the purge there are
always patients who need to be treated
so you can't just shut down hospitals
for 12 hours the same as you do with
emergency services it's been stated in
the movies that certain locations and
people are protected and in this episode
the protection of hospitals is confirmed
however Miguel finds out that the
rehabilitation center his sister had
been staying in does not have the same
protection this doesn't make a whole lot
of sense from an operational standpoint
because these patients would need the
same constant care that a hospital
patient would need but try looking at it
from the nffa standpoint rehab centers
are filled with those that they don't
deem fit for society whereas hospitals
will house some of their own in fact
only the rich will be able to afford
long hospital stays so it makes sense to
have them be a safe haven
Miguel's search for his sister
eventually leads him to a set of
abandoned buildings from outside it
would appear that they're still in
support of the purge as you can see from
the blue flower mural on the wall
skeleton figures as
and what appears to be a caricature of a
new founding father
however the inside looks like it was
once the center of a civil rights
movement there are paintings of civil
rights figures like Martin Luther King
jr. and they're also quotes repeated on
the wall I freed a thousand slaves I
could have freed more if only they knew
they were slaves I looked it up and
apparently this is widely known as a
quote by Harriet Tubman although there's
no proof that she actually said it but
the meaning still stands there's also an
MLK quote almost always the creative
dedicated minority has made the world
better
the name Assata Shakur who is known for
murdering a state trooper and using
violence to further her agenda also
appears on the wall the second of the
three main story lines follows a woman
named Jane who works for an equity firm
and is forced to work on purge night a
private equity firm usually manages
investment funds investment funds are
similar to the purge itself and that
they involve a pool of investors taking
advantage of the size of their group
it's very similar to how the nffa bands
together to take advantage of the
lower-class
Janes trying to work herself up to a
position of power within the company
when visiting her mom in hospital her
mom mentioned something about Jane
needing to get a promotion telling her
that she would have it if she had just
played the game Jane doesn't want to
talk about it it seems like a sore
subject but I'm guessing that Jane's
bosses are corrupt and asked her to take
part in some shady business tactics or
possibly tried to take advantage of her
there is some evidence of her employer's
inappropriate behavior when one of her
bosses joins the rest of the workers via
video call and Jane calls him out for
being the type of person to eavesdrop
then in the most creepy way possible he
tells her that he's always watching and
listening outside of the building she
works in you can see a sign that reads
the price of freedom it can be seen from
within these walls if that's not a red
flag I don't know what is but on purge
night she's got some tricks of her own
she goes down and makes some kind of
transaction it looks like she's ordering
it hits
judging from the tension between her and
her boss I've got a guest that she's
ordering a hit on him but my guest is
that her boss has cameras and
microphones hidden all over the building
and finds out about her hit man she
thinks she's safe at work but if her
boss comes after her she could actually
be in great danger
the last storyline follows Jenna and
Rick a married couple who attend an nffa
party in order to try to close a deal to
get funding for their business after
they leave the house you
I notice a sign in the front yard
reading sand insecurity if you remember
back to the original purge film James
Sandin the father of the family in that
movie sold security systems for the
purge but his chief systems came back to
bite him when his neighbors turned
against him for overcharging on their
security systems in the end James was
killed but according to this sign his
company lived on without him when they
arrived at the house in addition to the
blue flowers there are Eagle statues
that represent the Eagle of the nffa
logo once the party begins the hosts
give out gifts to their guests in the
form of purge masks each one is a cutout
face of a serial killer and when I saw
the characters putting these on I pretty
much almost lost it they look exactly
like my found flakes mask that I've been
wearing during the purge they cut out
eyes the expressions the greyscale I
mean I wasn't aware you watched my show
mr. demonic oh I'm kidding about that
last part of course but anyways Rick
gets David Richard Berkowitz a serial
killer from the 70s who took out eight
people in separate attacks Jenna ends up
getting Suzanne's and nice Atkins who
was a follower of Charles Manson and she
had claimed nine lives back in the
summer of 69 I'm assuming those were the
best days of her life because the rest
of them were spent in jail I'll be
keeping an eye on Rick and Jenna to see
if the mass that they receive end up
foreshadowing anything with their
characters so that covers all of the
things you miss involving the main
characters but before our purge time is
up I wanted to point out that some
things could have snuck past you about
the world and the time period it's
mentioned on TV that this could be the
biggest perch ever due to the massive
amount of purge material sold leading up
to it like this guy who buys 12 rolls of
toilet paper I mean I can only imagine
he got caught taping some house as a kid
on Halloween or something and so he
decided to spend his purge night where
he can literally do anything by the way
throwing toilet paper kind of old miss
Jenkins place when there's nothing she
can do about it but if the reports are
correct and this is the biggest purge it
makes sense how this could lead into the
purge election year with people being
devastated by the damage of this year's
purge and really turning against the
idea they'd be looking for a candidate
to get behind in the next election which
would take place in 2032 because senator
rone doesn't win the White House
until two elections later in 2040 it's
gonna be hard to see from this image but
if you zoom in on any license plate in
the show the individual state insignia
are gone in favor of a design that says
a nation reborn I wonder if the 50 state
system was somehow removed by the nffa
in order to keep them in power another
point on the current political situation
America is currently at war when Miguel
explains that he just got back from the
Marines and one of the guys chimes in
and asked why he isn't off still
fighting so although we know that
there's a war going on we don't really
know any of the details the last thing
to know is that something major happened
on last year's purge as Jayne signs in
at her office the following can be heard
on the radio in the background
[Music]
we'll see if any clever poachers are
able to duplicate last year's epic purge
night heist of southern hold us back
we're for mass murderers were able to
get away with 12 counts of and that's
all we can really hear but it'll be
interesting to see if we can learn more
about that if you are interested in
learning more there are nine more
episodes of the purge lined up for you
to Tuesday's on USA Network the only
question is will you hide or will you
see be sure to tune in next week to see
if you can spot the happy deathday
reference they dropped in the second
episode if you're excited to see that
then go ahead and leave a like on this
video and make sure you're up to date on
all the things you might have missed in
your favorite horror franchises remember
to subscribe to seize these worlds for
new Horrors every week bring that death
bell for notifications and I'll see you
in the next one assuming we both survive